My whole life changed
with five simple words
delivered casually
by a relative at a party:
"You know you're autistic, right?"
Initially, I rejected the idea.
I was 30 and my knowledge of autism
was based on TV caricatures and digs
from people who suggested
anyone behaving poorly
must be "on the spectrum".
I thought autistic people were
math wizards who lacked empathy
and loved trains.
Of course, there's no one way
to be autistic,
and autism can present
quite differently
in different people.
I'm a loudmouth creative
with an overactive empathy chip
who can barely add two digits
together.
And I couldn't care less
about trains.
My story is more common
than you'd think.
Growing up, my autistic meltdowns -
a totally involuntary response
to emotional or physical overload,
were dismissed as attention seeking.
This was really confusing and scary
as I came to believe
I was somehow acting out on purpose.
Add to that sensory sensitivities,
making many lights, noises, smells,
textures and tastes overwhelming
and painful,
as well as severe aversions
to almost all food
and "spoilt brat" was added
to the charge sheet.
My tendency to simply blurt out
uncomfortable truths
was misinterpreted by others
as manipulative.
It seemed that everything I did
was misunderstood,
and so I began
to over-explain myself,
a trait others found annoying.
By the time I was seven,
my self-esteem began to plummet.
I tried to hide my difficulties
and differences by disguising
my obsessive interests or choosing
similar ones to the other girls,
like boybands, for example -
in my case Hanson,
even if I never did marry Zac.
This is called masking.
And it's something
many autistic girls do
to try to blend in.
Unfortunately, the long-term effects
of masking
can cause mental health issues
and autistic burn-out,
an experience lots
of autistic people can relate to,
where our difficulties
are suddenly magnified
and it becomes impossible
to participate in the world.
Autism is often presented
as an illness to be cured,
when in fact it's just a different
way of experiencing the world.
While it comes with its downsides,
it also has benefits.
Contrary to stereotypes,
autistic people can be creative,
emotional and highly empathetic,
kind while saying
exactly what we mean.
I care deeply about social justice.
I connect with animals.
I get untold joy
from my intense interests.
And when my sensory sensitivities
are focused on positive experiences
like music, it can be wonderful.
Around one in 100 people in the UK
are thought to be autistic,
with three times as many boys
as girls being diagnosed.
Like many areas of medical research,
women are under-represented
in studies and many
of the diagnostic criteria
for autism were developed
with men in mind.
Over the past decade,
our understanding of how autism
can manifest differently in girls
and women
and also how our autistic behaviours
can be interpreted differently
has changed.
But research still has
a long way to go.
Until I was diagnosed as autistic,
I thought I was a broken,
terrible person.
My diagnosis gave me a framework
to explain my experience
to loved ones and the wider world.
Meeting other autistic people
gave me permission to understand
and even begin to like myself.
Being autistic isn't all roses
and sunshine.
Like anything, it comes
with its pros and cons.
Some people see autism
as an illness,
whilst others call it a superpower.
To me, it's neither.
It's simply the blueprint
for who I am,
and to cure me of my autism
would be to cure me of myself.
My hope is that society comes
to better understand
the autistic experience
so that future generations
of women are able to be diagnosed
at an earlier age.
That way they can be given
the support they need to thrive,
have self-confidence, and relate
to the world on their own terms
as their unique, brilliant
autistic selves.